[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all very much my name is
chilli ma I am Nigerian it's that I am
also a front-end developer at a new lab
I love to drink tea that's a fun fact
about me
another fun fact about me is this is my
first time speaking at a conference
[Applause]
so please be kind to me okay okay so I'm
going to just go straight into my talk I
wanted to when I was preparing my slides
I thought about how do I talk to people
about how we can all get along about the
diversity about everything that happens
in our community so I decided okay let
me look at what has happened in the past
and I who remembers the dr. Katie Bowman
saga the woman who discovered she was
part of the team of the people who
discovered the black hole who remembers
just okay who remembers how much she was
bullied on Twitter on Hacker News who
yeah who felt very angry I know you
wanted to find those guys all read it
good so it means we are all together who
also was ever posted a question on Stack
Overflow good who has I like - I like
the communication we have who remembers
who has ever like posted the question
and then got seen like a very negative
feedback oh yeah we're all in the same
shoes my personal story is I posted my
first time ever I posted a question on
Stack Overflow and I think I thought
about jQuery something about jQuery and
somebody said can't you read right and
said go read the docs if you can read go
read the docs and I was wondering after
a refreshing like for over three minutes
to get an answer and somebody said go
read the docs I mean I'm coming from the
dogs right if I'm coming from the dogs
and I came to Stack Overflow where
everyone is meant to ask questions and
I'm getting that kind of feedback how do
you want me to feel as a beginner right
and that was very different stating for
me I tried to remember all the stories
when I was coming up with this talk
today we're going to talk about we're
going to have a conversation about why
this talk is important we are also going
to look at practical examples we are
going to look at a proven solution we
are going to explore ways to apply this
solution to our community are also going
to look at how this walking on this
problem can actually benefit us as
individuals and help our community
why do we need to have this conversation
we need to have this conversation
because we are unique in so many ways we
all come from different backgrounds we
have different parents even if we're
sisters and brothers I mean we have
different ideologies right we need to
have this conversation because despite
our differences instead of embracing our
differences we are actually making it
allowing it cause discord and discomfort
disconnect and friction within our
community and amongst ourselves okay
practical examples I'm going to talk
about the condescending tone if you've
ever asked the question on reddit and
then use somebody down voted your
question right or somebody said this is
not right for this trench is it called a
tread or a rule right somebody says this
is not right or Stack Overflow have you
ever like been in code review with your
manager or your team lead and somebody
says or your team lead says what you did
makes no sense right maybe put you down
very in a very bad way how did you feel
did you feel anger did you feel sad if
you felt anger just okay who felt sad
about it okay so the reason I'm talking
about the condescending tone is I think
we have a problem as engineers in our
community we have a problem with
communicating I'm not sure everyone
wakes up in the morning and says I want
to be condescending I don't think people
wake up and say every junior developer
in my office has to hear it from me
today I think it's because we do not
know how to communicate and it's
especially because when we learn
something new I am due to beauty of this
too when we learn something new we think
oh yeah anyone that wants to talk to me
today has to know that I've laid stress
let's say you learned about react hooks
for example so you tell yourself anyone
that access me this question I don't
even think we look in the mirror and I
say this is what we're going to say all
this all we're going to do but somebody
you know developers say some things are
like no that's not how it's meant to be
done and we do not actually like tell
them why we just put them down and that
is not nice this is a problem in our
community and we need to work on this
yeah
and three deaths also one that gets to
meet the most is the back end versus
front end if you've ever had about
people say front end developers who not
do a lot of work front end developers
are just there I mean you can relate to
what I'm trying to see here people have
been in situations where people tell me
I'm a front-end developer so I'm not
doing as much work as the back-end
developer so I shouldn't probably get as
paid as much
oh I'm just there for decoration or
something and maybe they did not mean it
that way maybe I'm trying to be nice to
them and they did not really mean it
that way but this is a problem we're
having so much division in our community
because we feel that there are some
people who are doing all the work and
some people are doing absolutely nothing
developers versus non developers I
actually went around talking to people
about this I spoke to designers I spoke
to people in the grid's team I spoke to
sales I spoke to markets and I spoke to
logistics and people actually feel that
we don't treat them nice shame on all of
us we don't show them nice we do not
think that they play an important role
in the company and that is really bad we
need to work on this everyone in the
company is working hard to make the
company profitable we shouldn't make
them feel that we are smarter than them
we shouldn't make them feel that we're
the most hard-working or we're doing the
most important job I mean if we finish
working on the product and there is
nobody to sell the products there's no
there are no salespeople or markets in
people do you think the world will see
what we've done now okay as the tech
community we must treat documentation I
saw the street and I had to put it as
it's a community we must treat
documentation markets and logistic
infrastructure et Cie work as much
respect as engineering we do not and we
have to actually work on this yeah I'll
just give you a minute to read
okay this one we can all relate to it
and I was guilty of this a few months
ago I used to be a reactor developer and
I got hired to be a view Juris developer
but guess
I was always I always had the bias
against vue.js developers I always said
the view was trash right I mean why
would you use view when you can use
react why would you use view when you
can use angular but I'm here to tell us
today that this framework was students
shouldn't be so we shouldn't have this
world's I mean they're all tools right
we are supposed to use this tools to
actually work on something that create
product the fact that we've had one bad
experience does not mean that we should
spread our biases and if you ask me why
I had the bias against view I I don't
know maybe somebody told me view was
trash and I said okay everyone view is
trash and I did not even put in the work
and that is if we actually set ourselves
why do we hit angular why do we hit view
why do we hit jQuery we sometimes we do
not have a concrete answer it's just
because somebody told us or we've seen
maybe our mentors I've talked about this
on Twitter and then we said okay I mean
if he's smarter than me and he says view
is trash then maybe view is trash right
I think this is a problem and we should
I mean it's discouraging beginners from
actually spreading their wings where
this currently beginners from being
open-minded because we are just being
biased
how can we make this better
empathy I'm sure we've heard about
empathy so many times so this is not new
and I will not waste our times but
empathy in the simplest forms is trying
to put yourself in other people's shoes
is trying to understand why people are
acting the way their action is trying to
wimp somebody flares up is trying to
understand why is this person doing this
right that's what empathy really is
feeling with a group of people so not
just your colleagues also people in
different community from different
demographics so I'm sure if I asked
everyone here to do we're going to say
yeah we show empathy right and that's
why I put them more in the brackets
because we are all we all show empathy
here so how can we show more empathy
towards one another it starts with a
question how would I feel if I was on
the receiving end so let's say you're
going through Stack Overflow and you see
an a question now you want to answer the
question before you press send why don't
you ask yourself
if I was beginning if I was a biggie now
or if I asked this question how would I
feel if I got this answer I'm about to
send right that's a question we should
ask each other before or acts ourselves
rather before we do anything put
yourself in the shoes of the person who
you are about to bully put yourself in
the shoes of the person who you're about
to reply I mean it may seem like it's
just a random answer but would you like
it if you got that kind of answer from
people I'm sure it's no how wise your
empathy I'm sure we already know we've
sing talks about why you should show
empathy but I would just list a few of
them you should show empathy because you
are going to be treated better you're
going to treat other people with care
you should also show empathy because you
understand the needs of your colleagues
and you also understand the needs of
your end users you should show empathy
because when you show empathy actually
understand people what people say when
you're not even speaking you understand
my body language and it's uncomfortable
you understand that this is not
something I want to hear you will also
learn how to deal with conflicts better
also I understand that we did not start
this problem I mean we've had it's I
mean I mean I feel that when we start a
very famous attack we were answered in
very rude ways but I mean we have the
solution we can actually take a stand
and say we do not we shouldn't speak to
other people this way right so how do we
how do we actually come together to make
this better
I mean imagine a community where they're
momentous and very few bullies just
maybe we should just tune into our like
in our minds right and try to imagine
we're a community where you are more
mentors less bullies imagine a community
where you can actually ask questions or
Stack Overflow or reddit or anywhere and
not get maybe rude answers imagine a
community where everyone from every
demographic is welcome imagine a
community where no gatekeepers people
want to see you succeed nobody is trying
to bring you down imagine it imagine how
much we can achieve if we are focused on
bringing each other up and not trying to
bring each other down
in closing I encourage you to see
something say something
I encourage you to pause or encourage
you to listen I encourage you to change
your point of view occur I will also
encourage you to apologize when do I
will also encourage you to speak up for
others because it's not enough that we
understand how to empathize but when you
see somebody actually bringing other
people down say something about it
our I encourage you to share what you
know and trust me our community to be
better for it thank you
[Music]